through your mind right before you say
jump off a cliff on a motorcycle
there's a lot going on I'm thinking
about performance I'm thinking about the
camera you know we have drone cameras
out there I have a helicopter going
across the ramp
and I'm thinking about the performance
I'm thinking about opening as late as
possible when I get down because the
shot has to be following I'm thinking
about the cameras that are on the edge
of the cliff I'm hoping I'm not going to
get blown off the ramp by the down wash
of the helicopter so our timing has to
be right
um hoping I don't get into a bit of a
tumble and just focus on performance and
there's a lot of things going on as I'm
going down that ramp and actually when
I'm going down the ramp there's a
certain point where it's a go no-go line
where I have to either I'm committed
once a wheel passes that I'm now
committed to the to go off that ramp so
we gotta do it there's a there's a there
was a lot going on that day